Costigan resume beer back welcome to
devil hat tire oh my god they are vital
tiny a lot of German seems to think I
hate them because a lot of times I speak
German in my videos but I like speaking
German it's it's funny let's see here so
this is supposed to be a co-op game
another one of those had the brother
Schlick Gruber to Austrian youth united
in their passion for art with nowhere to
unleash their fervor I don't know what
the fervor is but I assume it's their
pet until one day they decided upon a
cunning plan stacked on top of each
other they could enroll in the most
prestigious art school in Vienna under
the false but Don's of being in a car in
a girdle attacked one so he telling me
Hitler was two little boys trying to be
arts go God all right so I lean
apparently I owe everybody in the club
shake that ass for me shake that ass
what the Dorson all right is that what
the [ __ ] in German or some [ __ ] do you
know what the doorway that big fat butt
wiggle wiggle that is ma I am French
that would indeed be lovely just one
second sir let me move aside move oh oh
I follow the lines the lines things up
that doesn't work that doesn't work very
well I'm French so shut up all right
sorry yeah yeah
got a shot you're all right there this
is how you speak this is how you do art
you don't like well you can do is write
a [ __ ] that's a circle right there you
say that's check that it's a circle yes
what happened to my toys oh all right
then all right
ignore my torso being torn into million
pieces I will now examine neat we will
allow up it's fine actually it's fine
don't you worry cuz this star is gonna
join like your mum's
it's 5th of November this is really hard
but really hard I said let me focus on
this little heart it's not a heart maybe
that's why I'm so bad if that isn't a
heart I don't know what a heart is I
don't know what love is how the [ __ ] am
I supposed to do that MA yeah it's good
to drunk
Jesus maybe I'm drought let me lick your
[ __ ] alright let's do this properly
this is this is quite easy man mechanism
you do it a little better to us and oh
oh yeah bitte bitte oh yeah that is very
good very good indeed
oh how javonni I'm a melon cook this is
how you do art speed art
Haley hope having giving their very best
- lick lick Ruben still saw the dream
crushed by the rigorous admiration of
dicks act - a scent of evil what
everybody in the house put your hands up
watch their body length and
Oh such a weird game holy [ __ ]
Charles shouts fun penis shut smile ciao
try out see how on penis
yes that is very good dance you infidels
Oh
oh yeah Petey Petey Petey petition
petition the Hessian [ __ ] the
Kyle loves me they love to party as the
Germans they love they love me they love
my mustache but I both but most of all
they love my Swagger Bible does not have
swagger - OH
over here over here yes that is good
that is good yeah Oh Peter let me hear
it you sing it to once again blimp Shen
is anyone here a fan of blemishing but
yes you love blemish and OCHA well this
is very good very good I love this game
now we shall play our national anthem
I'm sorry I'm so sorry that's not funny
it's hilarious the country was that is
but the schlip Goebbels bigger remained
unsaturated troops are sent in all
directions to subjugate the paper left
evidence led me to get it bad downfall
this explains a lot this game actually
I'm not doubting this at all all right
all I wanted was to be and oh yeah
Hitler was an art artist wasn't he all
right let me show you how it's done you
imbeciles
yeah all right stupid alliance with that
stupid piece all right stupid stupid
Germans I am German I mean what just
wanted to burn out the club that's dope
- rynason - cosseted Venice oh that is
kleinen I'm a hood ah
if be known octopus if been an octopus
xun van and Madonna it been sneaking
home oh alright
let's say let's do this Super Mario I
played enough Nintendo games
alright let's let dice why can't no one
else do this
haha I'm the only one doing this cheat
all right dad that is good
I like to see how you see this pay very
close attention all right - good idea
Oh God Oh Oh careful that that is also
very good that is good yeah there we go
there nine it's me lovino karthik raja -
Ino nine your viola all right this is
funny it's funny to me I'm sorry I'm
just I'm just saying random [ __ ]
I don't it probably doesn't make any
sense Oh [ __ ] my fear that would
be a good pot ways for them like what
the [ __ ] we let these two kids control
us
Oh God I just don't want to die anymore
there we go ultimate all right just one
moment here mother now you think you're
so good with that little telephone tell
yourself a [ __ ] man Guardian Leviosa hit
magnet been Guardian love yes I love all
my German bros so much I I love them
extra much because they put up with me
speaking German all right
so don't don't hate and donate should we
go for - bonus - bonus in its v9i grasp
you're pretty sure huh
well whatever you in when they went in
wall school have you even seen Wally nah
oh we can't go under well that's a lot
easier
[ __ ] the bonuses man it's like [ __ ] the
police but bonuses Oh God
don't fall mine for all right that is
Klein in your lunch second
froggen Howard Ames dice asked all right
all right
ah you know I would be a terrible artist
too how the [ __ ] did I become Hitler
again all right well we went for a bonus
here I don't even know why yes Oh
ha ha my thought my god this is really
hard
ah hi I prefer the dancing part all
right I'm all about love and dancing not
war is not my thing all right all right
easy that's what they said about your
mom's vagina but she still conceived
your piece of [ __ ] - - good that is very
good
oh god oh god oh god oh god Macario
Leviosa The Guardian Leviosa and
Guardian never you're sure they got it
[ __ ] me man this is really hard I'm
gonna complete this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
gentle now gentle gentle okay okay don't
[ __ ] up now you know what the doorway
that big shut up huh ah yes doctor
scordia oh that is good oh how long did
that take me armies fought in cities
fairly this Robin given in there all but
ultimately fail again and so with
another dream given up on their
adventure ended act 4 epilogue what the
[ __ ] oh my god
that was a great game that it's funny I
like some three games are better than a
lot of paid titles these days that was a
legit game I I really enjoyed it it's
creative beautiful art it's funny little
offensive but hey what are you gonna do
I hope you bros enjoy this episode go
ahead and leave it like if you did I had
a lot of fun at least hit subscribe to
become a bro today and I'll see you in
the next one stay awesome bros that's
always bro flushed